[Applaudissements]
quand j'avais 10 ans je suis allée chez
mon papy et dans le jardin il y avait
une toute petite caravane
de 4 mètres carrés
c'était une érivapock qui venait
d'acheter et en gros une erive Apple
c'est une caravane dans laquelle tu peux
à peine te tenir debout dans laquelle il
y a un lit et si tu mesures plus d'un
mètre 60 tu dors très très mal dedans
il y a une cuisine qui se résume à une
plaque de gaz la salle de bain c'est un
petit robinet en plastique avec un bol
en dessous
et il y a un placard dans lequel tu peux
mettre en gros trois culottes de
pantalon et un manteau
moi dans la vie
je suis plutôt basse
quand j'avais 10 ans je pense que je
mesure rien à mettre 10 il y a des
pizzas qui sont plus grandes qu'un mètre
10 j'en ai entendu parler
et du coup quand papy m'a fait visiter
la petite caravane
j'ai pété un plomb j'étais trop heureuse
je me suis dit
enfin une maison à la taille
c'était vraiment incroyable de rentrer
dans cette petite maison et j'ai joué
toute l'après-midi dans la caravane avec
mon papy en gros je trouvais ça
incroyable de pouvoir avoir une petite
maison avec tous les besoins en primaire
des humains accessibles boire manger
dormir et toute la journée j'ai joué
avec mon papy je lui dirai les poils de
nez et ensuite on transformait le salon
en cuisine et ensuite la cuisine en lit
etc et je jouais avec lui j'étais là
mais c'est pas possible on peut pas
faire des coquillettes en roulant et je
prenais ses mains dans les miennes c'est
ma plaine de cornes et toute
l'après-midi j'ai couru entre la
caravane et son atelier poussiéreux
et la caravane a été mise dans un garage
ou chez un ami
et j'ai plus jamais entendu parler de
cette caravane
jusqu'à 20 ans plus tard
on est en avril 2020 on sort en France
du premier confinement et ma vie est un
peu pourri
deux mois plus tôt j'ai reçu un mail du
mec avec qui je suis depuis deux ans un
mail de 10 lignes et où il me dit
franchement
nous deux pas trop
juste avant le confinement j'avais du
nez je kiffe mon entreprise
et je trouvais que cette entreprise
Corée trop après l'efficacité la
productivité et pas assez après
l'humanité
et je galère j'ai envie de changer de
vie mais je sais pas trop comment faire
et là
je me rappelle de la caravane de mon
grand-père
j'appelle ma mère elle me dit qu'elle
existe encore dans un garage et
puisqu'il y avait encore des pizzas qui
étaient plus grandes que moi puisque je
me dirais un mètre 53
je vais chercher la caravane je passe
mon permis et je décide de vivre deux
ans dans cette caravane
la caravane je l'ai appelé Tatiana
ce qui a donné des phrases très bizarres
pendant deux ans du genre ce midi je
fais à manger dans Tatiana
ou encore pire
ce soir j'ai hâte de m'endormir dans
Tatiana
ne sortez pas cette phrase du contexte
cette caravane elle m'a permis de
découvrir une autre vie qui consiste à
m'incruster dans le jardin des inconnus
en fait
en gros pendant deux ans j'ai vécu dans
le jardin de gens qui voulaient bien
m'accueillir et en échange ensemble on
fabriquait des objets écologiques donc
des composteurs des récupérateurs d'eau
de pluie des serres j'ai creusé des
mares lancer une dizaine de potagers
cuisiner végétarien et
j'ai découvert une vie faite de travaux
manuels de rencontres et de recherche
écologique
ça a changé ma vie j'ai rencontré mes
meilleures amies
et j'ai décidé de m'installer à
Montpellier
mon grand-père m'a changé la vie et il
ne le saura jamais
il est décédé en 2009
il a une leucémie et il allait toutes
les semaines à l'hôpital pour renouveler
entièrement son sang un jour il a dit à
ma maman j'ai l'impression que on guérit
pas de cette maladie et elle a confirmé
un jour il a dit ben cette semaine j'ai
pas envie d'y aller et il est parti
quelques jours plus tard paisiblement
et sur son lit de mort on pouvait voir
ses poils de nez qui dépassaient
j'ai pas pu lui dire à l'époque ni en
face ni par mail ni par message privé ni
par un like ou en partageant son poste
ou son réel qu'il allait changer ma vie
parce que je ne savais pas encore que
mon grand-père était un influenceur
et lui non plus
moi dans la vie
mon métier
c'est d'influencer les gens
peut-être que je peux vous donner plus
de détails parce que c'est pas très
clair en gros l'influence c'est un
métier si si non c'est un métier c'est
un métier papa non mais je te vois faire
non de la tête c'est un métier en fait
voilà oui c'est les journalistes qui le
disent
voilà je rigole mon père n'est pas dans
la salle
il serait jamais venu et
en gros moi ce que je fais dans la vie
c'est que je raconte des histoires j'en
fais des vidéos et je les mets sur
internet il y a beaucoup de gens qui
suivent ces histoires et qui rigolent à
tout ce que je raconte et en gros quand
je prends des décisions dans ma vie et
que j'en parle publiquement forcément ça
a peut-être une influence sur les gens
qui rigolent à mes blagues ça s'appelle
être influenceuse il y a plein de gens
qui font ce métier en France mais aussi
dans le monde il y a des gens qui sont
spécialisés dans les vidéos de
maquillage par exemple d'autres dans les
jeux vidéos
il y a des gens qui se filment en train
de commander des McDo qui arrivent en
jet privé pour
bref il y en a vraiment pour tous les
goûts quoi
on peut tous s'y retrouver
les influenceurs ont beaucoup d'impact
n'ayons pas peur des chiffres
un influenceur qui a 100000 followers un
taux de conversion de 2,5%. et personne
n'a rien compris je vous explique je par
exemple si une femme qui est suivie par
cent mille personnes et qu'elle décide
de se teindre en blond et ben
potentiellement dans la semaine qui suit
il y a 2500 personnes qui vont faire une
décoloration pour être blond
donc Natoo par exemple qui est une
influenceuse incroyable qui a 4 millions
d'abonnés si elle décide de se mettre au
violon
il y a 100 000 personnes
qui se mettent au violon
et 200000 par an désespéré
soit l'équivalent des habitants de
Genève avec des boules quies
la communication sera compliqué
moi en cumulé il y a à peu près 1
million de personnes
qui regardent mon travail et ils sont là
ce soir un bruit pour les avions de
danger rigole
ils sont dans mon téléphone
mon téléphone qui est en coulisse
mais j'ai fait une école de mime donc
vous avez tous compris
téléphone
7000 euros
et vous allez apprendre plein de choses
ce soir
bref
c'est cadeau et moi je suis pas payé
pour être ici hein
bref
souvent je fais des aventures et je l'ai
documente et j'en fais des vidéos sur
YouTube ou sur Instagram et là hier je
suis rentrée d'un grand voyage que j'ai
fait avec mon pote Matteo
on a décidé de faire Paris
Copenhague au Danemark à vélo
et oui
et oui je sens encore la transpiration
voilà je pense que cette odeur ne
quittera jamais mon corps
j'ai fait en fait je voulais je voulais
savoir si c'était possible de traverser
cinq pays à la force de mes mollets sans
aucune préparation physique
[Rires]
et la réponse c'est oui c'est possible
mais ça fait mal au cul vraiment
je suis resté 1600 km
assis sur le siège le moins confortable
du monde d'ailleurs je sais pas si on
peut dire que une selle c'est un siège
là par exemple vous êtes sur un siège
donc imaginez le même siège avec entre
le siège et vos fesses un boxeur
voilà qui s'entraîne du rock
tous les jours pendant un mois
ça a été l'un des plus beaux voyages de
ma vie
et là vous vous dites elle doit adorer
la sodomie mais non non non pas du tout
pas du tout enfin ça dépend quelles
conditions non c'est pas non je suis pas
là pour parler de ça OK
quand c'est consenti bon
bref j'ai adoré ce voyage parce que j'ai
appris plein de choses que j'aurais
jamais appris the si j'avais fait un
voyage en avion
par exemple j'ai appris qu'à 21h30
c'est l'heure de la teuf pour les
canards sauvages
je vous avais dit que vous interveniez
plus intelligente de t'aide
mais moi je vous donne des infos il y a
eu le numéro scientifique ornithologue
comme ça 21h30 la lumière s'éteint par
la lumière j'entends le soleil qui
descend c'est toutes mes connaissances
en terre qui tourne
la lumière c'est un et les canards
sauvages se réunissent par centaines
dans un champ en général le chant est à
côté de ma tante voilà vraiment il faut
une race party voilà et coin coin dans
tous les coins et fruits je les ailes
genre vraiment il s'enflamme je sais pas
ce qu'ils prennent mais c'est absolument
incroyable
mais moi je dénonce
non mais parce qu'on est là mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils font c'est canards tous
ensemble le soir personne pense à
moi je vous le dis tout de go je
s'il y a des parents qui ont un fils
canard qui se demande mais qu'est-ce
qu'il fait la nuit il prend des
substances
je m'égare
c'est ma mère qui rigole comme ça
je pense que je me suis vraiment rendu
compte de ce que ça voulait dire
l'influence pendant ce voyage parce que
je racontais tous les jours mes
aventures et ce genre de découverte
brillante ornithologique en story ok sur
Instagram donc il y avait des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui regardaient
ça et pendant un mois j'ai reçu des
messages de gens qui changeaient leur
vie inspirée par ce voyage il y a Léa
qui m'a expliqué qu'elle a qu'elle s'est
enfin décidé à faire 170 km à vélo mais
alors qu'elle avait jamais osé
ce couple Kim et Chloé qui a décidé de
décrire le nombre de fois où ils
allaient au travail à vélo à la place
d'y aller en voiture et la personne qui
avait le plus fait de vélo se faisait
inviter au resto à la fin de la semaine
ça c'est trop cool et aussi Chloé qui
s'est décidé à faire du bivouac pendant
9 jours alors qu'elle n'osait pas avant
et j'ai reçu un message super émouvant
aussi et je m'en souviendrai toujours du
jour où je l'ai lu en gros on avait déjà
établi le campement je lis son message
et je suis super émue je laisse le
portable dans l'attente et je vais me
balader dans la forêt
le soir quand tu fais du vélo tu es
vraiment fatigué mais c'est une bonne
fatigue tu vois et là c'était vraiment
magnifique il faisait douille il y avait
un coucher de soleil et il y avait des
toiles d'araignées avec des petites
gouttelettes d'eau sur les toiles
d'araignées qui étaient orange rose et
tout et il y a ces mots qui qui résonne
dans ma tête et j'ai envie de faire mes
besoins et je pense à ces mots voilà
très inspirants
vous avez déjà chié dans les bois
ça nécessite la position accroupie en
fait vous avez déjà fait 200 km de vélo
sans préparation
sa sollicite les mêmes chaînes
musculaires ok sauf que moi je m'en suis
rendu compte
dans cette position
c'est bien simple je ne peux pas me
relever
ok je suis coincé je me dis faut que je
m'accroche à quelque chose
et là j'avance un arbre vraiment à 2
mètres de moi et j'entame une traversée
en crève et je suis là
et c'est là que les mots de la bonnet me
reviennent en tête
tu es ma lumière
tu mets des décisions sont inspirées par
toi
[Musique]
quand je vois tes aventures je rêve de
faire la même chose avec mes proches
quoi
[Rires]
bon voilà je pense que je vous ai bien
résumé le métier d'influencer
[Rires]
influencer pour faire ce voyage à vélo
la raison pour laquelle j'avais envie de
traverser l'Europe à vélo c'est grâce à
un porte-clé
mon ami Matteo regarde le vélo à la télé
depuis qu'il est tout petit mon ami
Matteo n'est pas un porte-clé j'y arrive
je lui ai expliqué
un jour son papa lui offre un porte-clé
avec dessus dessiner le col du Galibier
et en gros c'est une montée très connue
du Tour de France à vélo
un jour il va en soirée il sort son
portefeuille pour payer une bière il y a
ses clés qui tombent avec le porte-clé
il y a un mec qui ramasse ses clés qui
lui donne et qui dit tiens tu fais du
vélo et il dit bah oui il m'a c'est
incroyable moi j'ai fait Nice Paris à
vélo là aujourd'hui enfin pas
aujourd'hui peut-être
et Matteo surpris lui pose plein de
questions ils discute pendant une heure
et ce jour là
OK
il y a beaucoup de gens qui me
remercient d'avoir parlé de ce voyage en
Story sur Instagram il me disent c'est
incroyable tu tu nous ouvres les yeux
sur une autre façon de voyager etc mais
ce voyage je l'ai pas fait toute seule
enfin je veux dire j'étais toute seule
sur le vélo et j'aurais bien aimé que ce
soit les jambes de quelqu'un d'autre qui
pousse mais je l'ai fait ben grâce à
plein de d'efforts de gens cumulés donc
la femme qui a fabriqué mon vélo le
chercheur qui a expliqué que c'était
plus polluant de prendre l'avion que de
faire du vélo la militante qui a
démocratisé cette cette idée le mec qui
a insisté pour qu'il y ait des pistes
cyclables à travers toute l'Europe bref
c'est si aujourd'hui il y a des abonnés
à moi qui vont au travail à vélo c'est
pas que grâce à moi c'est grâce à une
personne qu'un influencé une autre
personne qu'un influence une autre
personne qui a influencé une
influenceuse qui influence les
influencer
je viens d'improviser ce sera c'était
très bien prononcé
c'est vrai en plus
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que je
pense que ce pouvoir incroyable
d'influence que j'ai à travers mes
réseaux sociaux on l'a tous chacun à
notre échelle
parce que on va forcément croiser la vie
de quelqu'un un jour qui va voir ce
qu'on est en train de faire si je vous
demande aujourd'hui comment vous avez
entendu parler du métier que vous
exercez certains me diront sur Linkedin
d'autres me diront bah j'ai passé un
concours qui m'a permis qui m'a permis
d'accéder à ce poste
et d'autres me diront
[Musique]
je suis parti en soirée
et que Jacqueline
à la plage on mangera raclette c'est
très peu probable quand même tous ces
éléments ensemble mais vous vous avez
l'image
j'ai rencontré un mec qui s'appelait
Gilbert et ils sont tous vieux dans mon
histoire mais
et Gilbert m'a parlé de son métier dont
j'avais jamais entendu parler et ça a
fait vibrer mon cœur
et c'est comme ça qu'un soir vous vous
retrouvez à dire des phrases du genre et
ben
j'ai bossé toute la journée dans Tatiana
j'essaie d'expliquer dans mon travail à
tout le monde que les changements
individuels en écologie ont un impact
le GIEC qui est en gros un groupe de
scientifiques qui s'est réuni qui a
beaucoup travaillé et qui en a conclu
que si on faisait rien pour lutter
contre les réchauffement climatiques on
a les tous crever dans la trop de
souffrance je vous la fait bref dis que
les initiatives que les changements
individuels sont indispensables le GIEC
dit aussi que l'État les collectivités
les entreprises doivent mettre en place
des infrastructures pour rendre possible
ce changement mais il dit le changement
individuel est indispensable et tous les
jours je reçois des messages de gens qui
me disent ça sert à rien que je prenne
le vélo ça sert à rien que je
démissionne de mon taf ça sert à rien
que je mange moins de viande
et en vrai moi je pense que ça sert à
quelque chose parce que je savais pas
qu'il était possible de voyager à vélo
avant de voir dans mon champ de vision
un mec avec un cycliste molletonné au
niveau du cul et une toute petite
casquette
vous avez peut-être pas mais qui sont
des toutes petites casquettes vraiment
ça m'a perturbé pendant un mois j'avais
une casquette avec une visière de 2 cm
je mettais comme ça je voyais plus rien
je la mettais comme ça on aurait dit
Donald enfin bon
et en gros on est tous dans le champ de
vision de quelqu'un
c'est une métaphore
et bien sûr vous êtes dans mon champ de
vision là maintenant mais vous mettez
pas agiter votre Cup de règles zéro
déchet genre regarde c'est trop bien non
c'est bon c'est pas poli je parle OK
et bien sûr que vos décisions ont un
impact même sur une personne si vous
démissionnez de votre travail parce que
votre travail est trop polluant vos
collègues ne pourront plus fermer les
yeux sur qu'est-ce qui est polluant
si vous refusez de prendre l'avion pour
un déplacement professionnel votre
patronne sera obligé d'entendre
ce qu'est le bilan carbone
ça a de l'impact
si mon papy a pu être influenceur avant
que Tik Tok et Instagram existe
on peut tous être papy
ça veut pas dire qu'on est obligé de
boire du potage tous les soirs
bruyamment et d'avoir un vieil Opinel
quand lave jamais dans sa poche bon moi
pourquoi il faut ça elle est pas binôme
j'espère que son Opinel a été lavé
depuis
vous pouvez tout influencer quelqu'un de
haut ou de bas plus ou moins grand
qu'une pizza
alors à vos vies et bonne incarnation de
vos convictions et je m'excuse auprès de
tous les ornithologues pour tout ce que
j'ai pu dire ce soir qu'ils avaient
[Applaudissements]